foreign
[Music]
once again brings you the hottest news
from Hollywood there was a particularly
large amount of information this week
from DC and its new universe we also
take a look at the upcoming Super Bowl
and its Possible movie trailers and show
you the first images from the live
action series for one piece we also have
some exciting news for fans of The Last
of Us and tell you what's in the works
for Bad Boys 4 with Will Smith and
Martin Lawrence have fun watching
one piece is without a doubt one of the
most successful and best known manga
series of all time new content has been
published on a regular basis for almost
25 years and the corresponding anime is
likewise very popular among fans old and
young so far there are well over 1 000
episodes of the TV series and as many as
13 movie adaptations along with other tv
specials as well as trading cards and
video games so nobody can ever deny that
the fanbase of one piece is huge there
is one thing that the fan Community is
still unsure about however and that is
the planned series on Netflix
be released in a live action format and
thus leave the familiar realm of
animated films and series since anime is
often about over-the-top and comic-like
characters and situations many wonder
how this could be brought across with
real actors in a convincing way in order
to raise anticipation among fans two
images were posted a few days ago one of
them shows the main character Monkey D
Luffy as well as the announcement that
the ship will set sail this year the
other image shows the protagonist and a
few of his companions joining him on a
search for the mysterious treasure one
piece the reactions at least are not bad
many want to get involved with the live
action format even though the
experiences with similar projects from
other studios in the past were rather
disappointing like Cowboy Bebop for
example we're looking forward to more
details about the upcoming series given
the release date this year we should be
able to expect a first teaser soon we'll
be sure to keep you up to date
foreign
episode of the first season of The Last
of Us is not only exciting fans of the
game series but also newcomers to the
franchise alike even those who couldn't
get much out of the survival horror
genre before have been pleasantly
surprised by the HBO series it was
already clear beforehand that the first
season would largely cover the plot of
the first game by game developer naughty
dog and up to now speculations about a
second season have been persistent since
there is also a second game with an even
more extensive storyline than the
original however an official
confirmation from those responsible was
not given by the time episode 3 was
released this has since changed as it
was officially announced on the series
Twitter account a couple of days ago
that the Journey of Joel and Ellie will
continue for the time being fans of the
first season have six more episodes left
before the wait for new episodes begins
in mid-march but the question as to when
filming of the new season is scheduled
to begin remains unanswered after all
this will largely determine when we can
expect the second season the current
news about the upcoming season is also
overshadowed by the unexpected passing
of Annie worship who embodied Joel's
close friend Tess in the original game
just two days after the announcement of
another season worship died of cancer
which was not known to the public
leaving the entire industry in mourning
we assume that washing will still be
paid tribute to in the course of the
season after all the 45 year old was not
only able to play her role impressively
but was also very popular with her
colleagues how the story will go on
after the end of the last episode is
unclear after all there are still enough
story lines left open between the first
and second games which were released
seven years apart some of these were
barely or not at all dealt with in The
Last of Us Part 2 from 2020 so there is
certainly a need for additional stories
patience is still required until there
is absolute Clarity regarding the plot
of season two for now we're looking
forward to the other episodes
the fans high expectations have been
more than met so far
this week there was particularly
extensive news from DC after much
speculation in recent weeks it is now
clear how things will continue after the
release of the four upcoming films The
Flash Blue Beetle Shazam 2 Fury of the
Gods and Aquaman and the lost kingdom in
2023 similar to the MCU there will be
different phases or rather chapters in
which a certain amount of projects will
be released the chapters have a
thematically appropriate title with the
first section being called Gods and
Monsters but which movies and series can
we look forward to well James Gunn
revealed that in a short video on
Twitter here are the highlights one of
the new movies that was already apparent
beforehand is a new Superman after the
back and forth about the previous actor
Henry Cavill it was made clear some
weeks ago that they would start looking
for a new younger actor the planned film
which will be the first one of the new
chapter is titled Superman Legacy but
according to gun it will not be an
origin story The Script is written by
gun himself and there is speculation
that the DC boss will also be the
director the release date is set for
July 11
2025. one of the most anticipated
projects from chapter one is lanterns
the series is said to have two main
characters Hal Jordan who was played by
Ryan Reynolds in the 2011 film Green
Lantern and Jon Stewart who is likewise
also a green
many fans expressed particular
excitement about the way the series will
be made as it is said to be inspired by
True Detective this series belongs to
the best modern crime series above all
the first season with Matthew
McConaughey and Woody Harrelson
continues to have a large fan base to
this day we can therefore look forward
to a dark crime series with at least two
members of the Green Lantern Corps the
Brave and the Bold introduces the first
DCU Batman the exact cast is not known
yet but you will be able to see not only
the Dark Knight but also his colleague
Robin on the big screen again in this
case Robin is Damian Wayne Bruce Wayne's
son and according to Gunn his favorite
Robin he is a cunning murderer who will
surely cause chaos in a very special
father-son relationship
not only will Superman get his own
feature in chapter 1 but his female
counterpart Supergirl is also to get a
movie the focus is on the clear
difference between her and Superman
while the latter was able to spend a
reasonably comfortable life on Earth
Supergirl grew up in the Wilds of her
home planet until the age of 14 and had
to watch nearly all of her friends and
family being killed a significant
difference which will most likely also
be reflected in the way the film is made
with swapping a genuine horror flick is
to make its way into the DCU following
the cancellation of the series a few
years ago the company is now going to
produce its own feature film in keeping
with the genre it will be pretty dark
but in spite of the horror element it
will be equally related to the other
films in series the film is supposed to
be the last installment of chapter 1 and
should therefore deal with some
storylines that will then be taken up
into chapter 2. it's a bold move to end
the first chapter with a horror movie
since the genre has rarely been applied
to superhero movies in the past
besides talking about the many movies in
series from chapter 1 of the new DCU
James Gunn also discussed two movie
projects that are very well known beyond
the borders of DC and stand entirely for
themselves and therefore are now being
referred to under the term elseworlds
which is quite well known in the comic
book world the first film from the
elseworlds is Joker Folia dude the
sequel is an immediate continuation of
the popular first part from 2019 and the
main actor Joaquin Phoenix is to be
joined by Lady Gaga as Harley Quinn the
style of the film is said to resemble a
musical and there are plenty of rumors
regarding the plot in one of our
Originals we took a closer look at the
film so feel free to check it out if you
want to know more about the Joker sequel
the theatrical release is scheduled for
October 4th 2024. the second movie from
the elseworlds is the Batman 2. although
it is a known fact that a new Batman is
being sought for the DCU this one has
nothing to do with the already he
introduced Robert Pattinson as The Dark
Knight in terms of story the plot of the
first part from the year 2022 is
continued and accompanies Batman on his
journey as a young detective in Gotham
City also to be released is the Penguin
series which is set in the same universe
as the two films and as the name
suggests revolves around Colin Farrell
as the penguin as we have known for
quite a while the series will link the
two movies in terms of story and as a
result will also be released before the
Batman 2 which is scheduled to hit
theaters on October 3rd 2025. whether
and how it will continue after the
Batman 2 with Robert Pattinson and his
character is not yet known which DC
projects are you most looking forward to
in the coming years let us know in the
comments
foreign
the biggest American TV event of the
year will take place next week Super
Bowl 57 in addition to the sports event
and the famous halftime show the
commercials are also a big highlight as
are the trailers for the movie industry
half a minute of air time at the Super
Bowl costs a whopping 7 million US
Dollars we can therefore look forward to
a number of short but elaborately
produced spots Warner Brothers which
traditionally tends to hold back at the
Super Bowl will be joining in for a
change we can still expect at least one
trailer for the upcoming The Flash with
Ezra Miller moreover the rumor persists
that there will be some sort of sneak
preview of the upcoming DC Universe
after James Gunn and Peter saffron as
heads of the DC Studios have announced
some movies and series according to
deadline Universal is set to present two
movies namely Fast and Furious 10 and
cocaine bear especially the announcement
of The Fast and Furious trailer should
not surprise anyone after all the
franchise has always been a pop popular
guest at the Super Bowl in the past
years just before the big event there
will be a fast X party with Vin Diesel
in Los Angeles a launch party so to
speak where the ad campaigned for the
10th film in the series will officially
begin a 15-second spot is planned for
cocaine bear a particularly High number
of trailers can be expected from Disney
these include trailers for Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 and the Little Mermaid in
addition footage of the Pixar film
Elemental is reportedly being planned in
Jones 5 the dial of Destiny and Captain
Marvel 2 The Marvels may also get their
own previews however our source at
deadline did not want to give a final
statement on this Paramount is also
likely to dig deep into their pockets to
promote their upcoming projects a
minimum of three trailers are sure to be
released for Scream 6 Dungeons and
Dragons honor among Thieves and
Transformers rise of the beasts still
unclear are the participants of MGM and
Lionsgate which would have two top-class
movies in store with Creed 3 and John
Wick chapter 4. however they are not
always represented at the Super Bowl the
same is true for Sony which last took
part in 2017.
Will Smith's famous slap to the face was
undoubtedly one of the highlights of
last year's Academy Awards Smith's
unforeseen Outburst due to satirical
comments about his wife Jada caused the
54 year old a lot of ridicule and Malice
for a long time it was unclear whether
Smith's career would recover from this
incident as his loss of control in front
of running cameras was certainly among
the low points of his long-acting career
in a joint video Smith and his film
colleague Martin Lawrence have now
announced that a fourth part of the Bad
Boys film series is officially in the
works in addition to the two leading
actors the two bad boys for Life
directors Adele lrb and Bilal fala as
well as screenwriter Chris Bremner are
also set to return with the third
installment released almost 25 years
after the original fans can now look
forward to the second Bad Boys movie
within a few years sadly there is no
plan released it yet but this should
change soon given that the production is
already in progress we are deaf
definitely looking forward to more news
on this project
now you're up to date again when it
comes to Hollywood and the white those
of you who have already seen the
spectacular new Avatar movie in theaters
you may be interested in checking out
our latest original about Avatar 3 the
seed Bearer as the next installment is
set for release in 2024. thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]